The song that, I imagine,
for many of you needs no
introduction, but for a
few of you who may not be
familiar with it, that's one
of the great anthems of the
civil rights movement, "We
Shall Overcome." You're
actually lucky, I'm a--in
past years I've had the TAs
get up and sing it with me,
I've had the class get up
and sing it.
For some reason,
I'm a--I'm, I'm absolving
all of us of that kind of
performance. I play it here
for reasons that will become
much more clear
later on in the lecture,
but this is--this
piece of music,
"We Shall Overcome," is one
of sort of the anthems of
familiarity, of
memory, about the movement,
and for very good reasons.
But as part of my larger
project of trying to help
us understand a different
notion of what the movement
was really all about,
I want to throw the
song out to your senses,
leave it dangling
there for a while,
and come back and sort
of reinterpret it as this
lecture goes forward, as
much as I'm reinterpreting
the movement in many
ways itself. Let me,
with that caveat out
there, that introduction,
reading Fire Next Time,
James Baldwin's quite
important,
quite famous book,
I thought I would really
begin the lecture with a
couple of quotes
from James Baldwin,
from this really fantastic
documentary film on James
Baldwin called The Price of
the Ticket. I'd encourage
you all to see
it at some point.
It's quite astonishing.
Baldwin says during this
documentary--he's, it's a,
it's archival footage. He's
talking to, it
looks like to me,
to be something like
an Oxford Round Table,
or, or, or here like
the Yale Political Union,
something to that
effect, clearly college-age
students. And he
declares to these students,
that "It comes as quite a
shock to discover that the
country to which you pledge
allegiance does not pledge
allegiance to you. It comes
as quite a shock to discover
that when you are a child
rooting for Gary Cooper to
shoot all the Indians,
that the Indians are you."
Gary Cooper, for
those who don't know,
it's a different generation,
great cinematic hero,
often played the good
guy, you know cowboys and
Indians.
And he realizes,
James Baldwin,
as a little child, as he's
rooting for Gary Cooper to
kill all the Indians, he
actually is the Indian.
Later on in the
same documentary,
Baldwin talking to
a studio audience,
being interviewed by one
of these talk shows. It's
poetic. He really
was poetic. He says,
"The day will come when you
will trust you more than you
do now (speaking to
presumptively a white
audience) and you will trust
me more than you do now. We
will trust each
other. I do believe,
I really do believe, in the
new Jerusalem. I really do
believe that we can all
become better than we are.
I know we can. But the
price is enormous and people
are not yet
willing to pay it."
Much of the 1960s is about
people coming to terms with
the fact of who they are
in the American pantheon,
the cowboys or the Indians,
and also coming to terms
with what the price of that
ticket is going to be. Now
I ended the last lecture
talking about the potential
failure of the
movement in Albany,
Georgia, when the white
authorities outsmart the
activists by not reacting.
And then I mentioned,
along comes Bull Connor, who
as King would say later on,
was the most important
person for the success of
the movement, because of the
severity of his actions.
Bull Connor's the
Commissioner of Public
Safety. I mean, I'll be
skirting along this very
quickly, since you
watched the documentary,
4 Little Girls, and
you know a lot of this,
this history and saw some
of the images as well. He's
the Commissioner of Public
Safety and he's running for
mayor. The
election becomes,
I'll just say, fraught
with complication. There's
already
incredible tensions in,
in Birmingham over
issues that were similar to
Montgomery in terms of who
could shop in what stores,
and in fact, on the
ground in Birmingham,
store owners were very
willing at this point,
because of the threat of
economic warfare with the,
with the black
buying population,
very willing to
integrate the stores,
but Bull Connor says no.
And Connor is essentially
running, running the city.
So things are brought to a
head.King, who's
not in Birmingham,
is asked to come by the
Reverend Fred Shuttlesworth,
who is the head of a civil
rights--sort of organizing
civil rights
activism in Birmingham,
through a group called the
Alabama Christian Movement
for Human Rights, the
for Human Rights. It is
essentially the NAACP.
I mentioned in the last
lecture that NAACP's books
would be opened up by,
by state governments,
which would be essentially a
threat to lose jobs and to,
and to be harassed, to
even be killed. Other
organization--organizations
spring up to replace the
NAACP. In this case,
it's the Alabama Christian
Movement for Human Rights.
Shuttlesworth calls King to
Birmingham, knowing that
King more than anybody else
has the ability to
electrify a population,
and frankly to antagonize
a population as well.
Birmingham had already been
the witness or home to all
kinds of violence.
Between '57 and '63,
it had earned its nickname
of "Bombingham." There were
eighteen unsolved
bombings in the city in,
in black neighborhoods,
excuse me. City parks had
been closed in
1962. Playgrounds,
and pools, and golf courses
had gone private. All these
actions to prevent the
gathering of people,
activists, black people, and
also to prevent an attempt
to force the integration
of public spaces. So
playgrounds, golf courses,
and pools go private. City
on edge.King comes to
Birmingham and willfully
gets arrested. He knows
he's going to get arrested.
He's trying to brew up
crisis. But unlike the
police in Albany,
Georgia, who just,
you know, relaxed and let
things go and stayed in
touch with everybody,
Birmingham has not evolved
that way in the police
force. They throw King into
solitary. There's no word
coming from him. This is
actually terrifying. This
is an era when people would
disappear, and King being
such a high profile person
was not protected from
disappearing. Coretta Scott
King is frantic, wanting to
at least get reassurances
that her husband's alive,
not just safe but alive.
[coughs] Excuse me. John
F. Kennedy is currently the
President, been elected,
and he gets involved,
much like he did when he
was the candidate for the
presidency, and seeks
guarantees of King's safety
and that he's treated well.
While King is in jail,
a number of
clergy in Birmingham,
white clergy, moderates, are
basically upset that King is
coming in from out of
town, out of the blue,
and is
antagonizing the situation,
stirring up trouble,
and essentially is
telling--publish--they
publish a newspaper ad and
basically telling King
to slow things down,
to calm down, to, to
lower the temperature.King
responds by writing one of
the great protest documents
and letters, and that's
the "Letter from Birmingham
Jail." Now the "Letter from
Birmingham Jail" is not in
your reader but, you
know, it's online.
I hope you've actually
already looked at it. It's
not in your reader because
the King estate is rather
protective of King's legacy
and how much people are
going to pay to have his
words published. I'm being
extremely politic in saying
this. But the document is
one of the most important
documents in American
protest history. One of
the most frequently quoted
passages is one I shall now
quote as well. It brings
together King's
passion, of course,
his eloquence, but also
humanizes this in a way that
connected with many
people. This was an,
an immediate sensation.
King is responding to these,
these ministers and says,
"We have waited for more
than 340 years for our
constitutional and God-given
rights.
The nations of Asia and
Africa are moving with
jet-like speed
toward gaining political
independence, but we stiff
creep at horse-and-buggy
pace--still creep at
horse-and-buggy pace toward
gaining a cup of
coffee at a lunch counter.
Perhaps it is easy for those
who have never felt the
stinging dark--darts
of segregation to say,
'Wait.' But you--when you
have seen vicious mobs lynch
your mothers and fathers at
will and drown your sisters
and brothers at whim; when
you have seen hate-filled
policemen curse, kick
and even kill your black
brothers and sisters; when
you see the vast majority of
your twenty million negro
brothers smothering in an
airtight cage of poverty
in the midst of an affluent
society; when you suddenly
find your tongue twisted and
your speech stammering as
you seek to explain to your
six-year-old daughter why
she can't go to the public
amusement park that has
just been advertised on
television, and see tears
welling up in her eyes when
she is told that Funtown is
closed to colored children,
and see ominous clouds of
inferiority beginning to
form in her
little mental sky,
and see her beginning to
distort her personality by
developing an unconscious
bitterness toward white
people; when you have to
concoct an answer for a
five-year-old son
who is asking: 'Daddy,
why do white people treat
colored people so mean?';
when you take a cross-county
drive and find it necessary
to sleep night after night
in the uncomfortable corners
of your automobile because
no motel will accept you;
when you are humiliated day
in and day out by nagging
signs reading
'white' and 'colored';
when your first
name becomes 'nigger,
your middle name becomes
'boy' however old you are,
and your last
name becomes 'John,
and your wife and
mother are never given the
respected title 'Mrs.'; when
you are harried by day and
hunted--haunted by night
by the fact that you are a
negro, living
constantly at tiptoe stance,
never quite knowing
what to expect next,
and are plagued with inner
fears and outer resentments;
when you, when you
are forever fighting a
degenerating
sense of 'nobodiness,
then you will understand
why we find it difficult to
wait.
There comes a time when
the cup of--cup of endurance
runs over, and men are no
longer willing to be plunged
into the abyss of despair.
I hope, sirs, you can
understand our legitimate
and unavoidable impatience."
Years later, James Baldwin,
in the same documentary I
mentioned, is interviewed
by somebody in the early
seventies, saying, you
know, "You're so angry,
you're so impatient.
These changes you're talking
about take time." He shoots
back, "You say it
takes time. It's taken my
father's time and
my mother's time,
my brother's and
sister's time,
my grandfather's and
grandmother's time,
my nephew's and niece's
time. How much time do you
want for your
so-called progress?"
What is the pace of change?
It's going too fast for
white moderates. Not
going nearly fast enough for
African Americans and white
activists. So King writes
the "Letter from Birmingham
Jail" over Easter weekend in
1963. Meanwhile, marches
are being organized in
Birmingham, organized from
the Sixteenth Street Baptist
Church, to try to call
attention to the general
plight that African
Americans face in
Birmingham, the injustice,
injustice of the situation.
And Bull Connor
responds, quite famously,
"I want to see
the dogs work,
and then, "Look at those
niggers run." As marches
are organized, he
would release the dogs,
order his deputies to
release the dogs. You've
seen the images, of course.
Open up the fire cannons.
They actually had a
tank, a police tank,
that was brought out to
terrorize the citizens. A
decision is made by King
and his circle to raise the
stakes. And by
raising the stakes,
that means using
children.By the end of the
first day, children marching
in defiance of orders,
leaving school, a thousand
children aged between six,
six and eighteen are thrown
in jail. By the next day,
the number
doubles. Robert F.
Kennedy, he was leading a
civil rights agenda for his
brother, John F.
Kennedy, Robert F.
Kennedy is beside himself.
He could not believe
that King would risk these
children's
lives, as he put it,
for the sake of
more media coverage,
more negative press.
This is what he was doing,
there's no doubt about
it, that King is trying to
antagonize the situation
and horrify the nation by
revealing what Bull
Connor would actually do,
and Bull Connor
took the bait.
He doesn't care. Birmingham
becomes a media circus,
as people from around the
country are horrified at
what they bear witness to.
With all the media around, a
truce is negotiated. Lunch
counters open to blacks,
they become integrated.
Promises are made
that blacks are going to
begin--going to get
hired in clerical and sales
positions, thus avoiding
economic boycotts.But that
doesn't mean there's
peace. Martin Luther King's
brother's house is bombed.
The hotel that was a staging
ground for a lot
of the organizers,
who were coming in
from out of town,
the hotel was
bombed. Federal troops,
Robert F.
Kennedy
convinces his brother,
"You've got to bring federal
troops if you want to have
stability." So federal
troops come and occupy
Birmingham to keep the
peace. While all of this is
going on, to speak of
the sort of the heightened
tension around various
hotspots in the South and
local and states' rights
versus federal rights,
James Meredith, a
few months earlier,
inspired by Kennedy's
election and inauguration,
applies for and is
accepted at Ole Miss,
the flagship
school in Mississippi,
where Mississippi's
elite get trained.
James Meredith, a
black man, of course,
integrates the school,
but only with federal
protection, but the federal
protection didn't matter,
since there were riots
on campus surrounding
Meredith's arrival. His
likeness is hung in effigy
and federal marshals are
killed.George Wallace,
governor of Alabama, who you
saw in an advanced stage of
his life in the documentary,
who when he was running for
election earlier in
his career and lost,
when he was a
moderate Democrat,
lost to a race
a, you know, a,
a race-wielding demagogue,
declared earlier that he
would never be
"out-niggered" again,
and becomes this creature,
spewing racism and populism
at every turn. Wallace,
at his inauguration,
declares, "Segregation
now, segregation tomorrow,
segregation
forever." In June of '63,
after the riots
in Birmingham,
Wallace participates in a
staged act of resistance.
He knows he's going
to lose it already,
but he goes through
this performance,
and he refuses to let the
University of Alabama be
integrated. And he
literally stands at the
doorway of the, I think,
the registrar's offices,
he's outside of
the building,
refusing to let these two
black students integrate
University of Alabama.
JFK knew about it. He'd
already dispatched people to
negotiate a situation,
and the federal government,
embodied in I think
is Nick Katzenbach,
essentially gets the
students in the school. So
the federal government is
now intervening in state
affairs in ways that,
that could lead to,
without exaggeration,
another kind of sectional
crisis.That night, the same
night that Wallace is moved
aside and the University
of Alabama is integrated,
John F.
Kennedy appears on
national TV. And he asks,
[clears throat] excuse me,
he asks for Congress to give
him legislation that would
give everyone the right to
be served in facilities that
are open to the public. He
declares--essentially asking
for a civil rights bill. He
declares, and I quote
here, "We are confronted,
excuse me, we are confronted
primarily with a moral
issue. It is as old as the
scriptures and yet as clear
as the American
Constitution,
linking the battle
that he wants to fight,
asking Congress to give
him the tools to fight,
a battle that is one, bound
up in the Constitution,
but is also bound up with
fundamental morality and an
ethical sense of life.
Astonishing for a President
to step out like that, so
astonishing that a man named
Byron de la Beckwith,
a white guy down in
Mississippi, snaps. And
hours after Kennedy--this is
broadcast nationally on the
news--hours after Kennedy
makes this declaration,
Byron de la Beckwith is
hiding behind some bushes
across the street from
Medgar Evers's house,
Medgar Evers being the,
the head of NAACP
in Mississippi.
He wanted to be also
involved in the Southern
Christian
Leadership Conference,
but they made him
pick and choose,
so he chose the NAACP.
Byron de la Beckwith
shoots Medgar Evers from a
high-powered
rifle, kills him,
the driveway of his home.
Beckwith is not sentenced
for thirty-five years.
It's part of a whole other
conversation we might have
at the end of the course
about what some might call
a generation in the South
trying to find
racial healing,
decades after the
events that these atrocities
happen. So JFK goes on
TV and says the federal
government needs to respond
to this moral failing in our
country. Medgar
Evers is murdered.
In due course, a civil
rights bill is introduced
that would outlaw
segregation in all
interstate public
accommodations. It would
allow the attorney general
to initiate suits for school
integration. And,
very importantly,
it would give the
attorney general power,
the power to stop funding
for any federal program
where discrimination is
found to have occurred.
It's a bill that's
mostly about enforcement,
saying the federal
government can get involved
via the attorney general
enforcing substantive and
real change, along the
lines of civil rights.King,
as the head of
SCLC, leaders of CORE,
Congress of Racial
Equality, NAACP,
SNCC, the
National Urban League,
come together. It's a group
that squabbles quite a bit,
but they come together and
they are committed to seeing
this bill actually
pass. And they declare,
much like A.
Philip Randolph--well
exactly like A.
Philip Randolph declared
some twenty-two years
earlier, they call for
a March on Washington.
Kennedy went
apoplectic. He goes,
"This kind of agitating is
going to kill any chance
that the civil rights bill
is going to pass. You have
to be calm and quiet, you
know. It's not so much a go
slow mentality,
but just be calm.
Don't agitate. Don't stir
up the water." Kennedy is
simply horrified.
But the civil rights leaders
have no intention of backing
down. The march happens at
the very end of August 1963,
August 28th.
Just over a month
before the march,
Kennedy relents and
actually endorses it.
So Kennedy's trying
for a solid month,
month and a half, to get
the march canceled quietly,
you know, working with these
civil rights leaders. It's
now quite customary for the
President to be talking with
civil rights
leaders, something that was
revolutionary in
1941. You know,
they're now called into the
White House with regularity,
or they're just talking to
him on the phone. Kennedy
realizes they're not
going to back down;
he decides to endorse the
march. But he endorses it
on a couple of terms: that
the federal government will
have control over
it, in the sense of,
if things get out of
line, we'll kill the sound
system. We reserve the
right to look at all the
speeches before they're
actually given. You know,
they, they're saying from a
peace and safety standpoint
that it's really about
trying to control this march
so it doesn't get out
of hand in the federal
government's terms. Now
it's important to think of
the march--we know a
lot about it from our,
you know, our civics
classes in high school,
and certainly it's part
of our sort of national
rhetoric of exceptionalism,
but there's a lot of things
we don't know
about the march,
that they don't talk about.
First of all,
just the name itself,
the March on Washington for
Jobs and Freedom. Jobs was
a major part of the
March on Washington.
It's not just King standing
up there talking about a
dream he's having.
It's labor movements,
religious organizations,
civil rights organizations,
working together, calling
for the passage of the civil
rights bill, calling for a
two dollar minimum wage,
calling for the immediate
desegregation of schools,
calling for a federal
public works program,
along the lines of New Deal
works program I talked about
a couple of weeks
ago, calling for,
calling for real federal
action to ban discrimination
in employment, not just
press conferences like the
FEPC used to do,
but real action.
So the goals of the March
on Washington for Jobs and
Freedom, passage of
civil rights bill,
minimum wage,
desegregated schools,
public works program, and
real federal action to ban
discrimination in
employment.The march is
remembered, of
course, as a benevolent,
benevolent and
transcendent moment,
but if you've already
done your reading in,
in the Marable
and Mullings book,
you'll know that the story's
a little more complicated
than that. John Lewis,
currently representative of
Congress, then the new head
of the Student Nonviolent
Coordinating Committee, John
Lewis has a chance to go to
the microphone, he
prepares a speech,
the original version of
which is in your text. It
is not a speech
about love and joy,
rainbows and unicorns,
and all that kind of lovely
stuff. It's a speech
that called out on the
Kennedy--blamed the Kennedy
government for its moral
failings. It
attacked the very hand that,
in a sense, "allowed"
the march to go forward.
And in many
people's opinions,
even if they
agreed with Lewis,
they're saying, "There's no
way that you can actually
say this, cause you will
antagonize to the point,
we will, this will kill
the civil rights bill."
And Lewis goes, "I'm going
to say what I'm going to
say."As word of that gets
leaked out to people who are
about to go on
up to the podium,
one of the
religious leaders,
Cardinal,
Cardinal--whose name,
last name I'm blanking
on. I'm thinking of other
cardinals in the
news for other reasons,
the last few
years--a, a cardinal says,
"I'll leave the
podium if you say this."
Walter Reuther
says, "If you say this,
I'm gone." Basically, at
the moment at--just before
the, the speakers go live,
there's a real chance the
whole thing is going to fall
apart. Lewis finally agrees
to give an edited
version of the speech,
and that's the speech that
he gives. And the people
out in the audience have no
idea about what's happened
behind stage.
They also don't know, mainly
because of what Lewis is
threatening to do, that
the administration had
positioned agents
by the loudspeakers,
control panels, to kill
the entire sound system,
to silence the march. And
who knows what would have
happened, had that actually
gone forward. So the
narrative behind
the march itself,
and, the, the, the how you
get to the march actually
happening and what's
actually said there,
is, is different than what
people normally have been
taught to consume.
What they've been taught to
consume is this:
[Martin Luther King,
Jr.:] So even though we face
difficulties of today and
tomorrow, I
still have a dream.
It is a dream deeply rooted
in the American dream.
I have a dream that one day
this nation will rise up and
live out the true meaning
of its creed: 'We hold these
truths to be self-evident,
that all men are created
equal.' I have a dream that
one day on the red hills of
Georgia, the sons of former
slaves and the sons of
former slave owners will be
able to sit down together at
the table of brotherhood.
I have a dream that one
day even the state of
Mississippi, a state
sweltering with the heat of
injustice, sweltering
with the heat of oppression,
will be transformed into
an oasis of freedom and
justice.
I have a dream that my four
little children will one day
live in a nation where they
will not be judged by the
color of their skin but
by the content of their
character.
I have a dream today!"
You all know these, this
passage. Whether you know
it by heart or not is a
different issue. In a
couple of weeks, when
we, the course resumes,
when we're getting into the
1980s and nineties and such,
we'll come back to this last
part of this. I wanted to
play this main section here,
because the last part is
actually used for different,
quite different purposes,
as we get into the
1990s, in a new era of,
sort of race politics, a
confusing era all the same.
But in this moment, this is,
I mean it's gorgeous. This
beautiful passage about a
person having a reverie
about possibility, thinking
about a day in which the
color of their skin is not
going to determine their
life chances. I have no
quarrel with celebrating
this part of the speech,
certainly. But what of
other parts of the speech?
How come we don't know a
part, very early on, five
paragraphs into his speech,
when he says: "In a sense
we've come to our nation's
capital to cash a check.
When the architects of
our republic wrote the
magnificent words of
the Constitution and the
Declaration of Independence,
they were signing a
promissory note to which
every American was to fall
heir.
This note was a
promise that all men,
yes, black men as
well as white men,
would be guaranteed the
'unalienable Rights' of
Law--of 'Life, Liberty and
the pursuit of Happiness.'
It is obvious today that
America has defaulted on
this promissory note,
insofar as her citizens of
color are concerned.
Instead of honoring
this sacred obligation,
America has given the
Negro people a bad check,
a check which has come
back marked 'insufficient
funds.'" That's a very--I
mean imagine if that was the
message that we grew up
in our elementary schools
listening to in
black history month,
as we all know, it's been
trotted out during that
particular month. That's a
very different message to
walk away from with the
March on Washington: America
has failed on its promise to
provide equality for all its
citizens, and it's couched
in the terms of capital.
Significantly different
speech if you just excerpt
that part. Or, what if
you excerpted this part?
[Martin Luther King, Jr.:]
We can never be satisfied as
long as the Negro is the
victim of the unspeakable
horrors of police brutality.
We can never be satisfied
as long as our bodies,
heavy with the
fatigue of travel,
cannot gain lodging in the
motels of the highways and
the hotels of the cities.
We cannot be satisfied as
long as the Negro's basic
mobility is from a smaller
ghetto to a larger one.
We can never be satisfied
as long as our children are
stripped of their selfhood
and robbed of their dignity
by signs stating: 'For
Whites Only.' We cannot be
satisfied as long as a Negro
in Mississippi cannot vote
and a Negro in New York
believes he has nothing for
which to vote.
No, no, we are
not satisfied,
and we will not be satisfied
until 'justice rolls down
like waters, and
righteousness like a mighty
stream.'" Now that's in
the middle of his speech,
as he's preparing for the
crescendo that would turn
into the "I Have a Dream"
sort of call and response,
in a sense. So you have a
King in the earliest part of
this speech talking about
the failures of the American
republic to abide by its own
Declaration of Independence
and its own Constitution.
The message hasn't changed
from the night before
the March on--excuse me,
the Montgomery bus
boycott, when King says,
"If we're wrong in all
of what we're doing,
the Supreme Court is wrong
and the Constitution is
wrong."
He's calling for the country
to live up to its legal
mandates and, of course, its
ethical mandates as well.
And he's also, although
he certainly abides by the
philosophy of
turning the other cheek,
it should not be allowed to
be mistaken for sort of the
positive and hopeful reverie
of the "I Have a Dream
moment." He is saying
we cannot be satisfied,
we cannot stop,
harkening back,
I think, to Du Bois who--W.
E.
B.
Du Bois, who died the
day before the March on
Washington. Talk
about, sort of,
theatrical timing, not to
make light of it. It's
rather astonishing though.
He died an expatriate in
Ghana, having essentially
been kicked out of--well
kicked himself
out of the country,
after the country took
his passport for a while,
for his alleged Communist
sympathizing. But Du Bois
was talking
about "returning,
returning from fighting,
returning fighting" and King
is saying the same thing,
"We can never be satisfied,
as long as you can't vote
in Mississippi and as long
as there's no reason to
vote in New York. And he's
harkening, by the
way, at that moment,
to the fact that--you know,
I've been talking about the
South a lot, and I will be
talking about the South some
more.
But as we'll see later
in a couple of weeks,
this is a national problem.
It's just articulated in
different ways. So what
would the narrative of the
"I Have a Dream" speech be,
if the title was: "We Can
Never Be Satisfied"?
Or if the title were:
"Insufficient Funds"?
That's a different kind of
speech. And we need to
think about the consequences
of these naming conventions,
of these excerpting
conventions, of these
ways that we learn about
individuals like King who
become mythic for every good
reason, I don't
want to dismiss it,
but become something other
than what they might have
been, if you just
looked at their rhetoric,
looked at their approach in
a slightly different angle.
All that said, there's no
denying the fact that right
after the march, there was
this sort of giddy feeling
of hope, of benevolence,
of transcendence. I can't
rewrite history that way.
There's a sense of real
change in the air, the
change that is shattered or,
excuse me, a sense that is
shattered two weeks later
when those four little
girls are blown to bits in
Birmingham.
Now the King you hear in "I
Have a Dream" or--speech or
Montgomery bus
boycott speech,
is a King who is
buoyant, hopeful,
angry perhaps,
concerned, but with a,
a narrative power that
suggests possibility in a
positive way. Let me play
a clip of a different King.
[Martin Luther King,
Jr.:]"These children,
unoffending,
innocent, and beautiful,
were the victims of one of
the most vicious and tragic
crimes ever perpetrated
against humanity.
And yet they died nobly.
They are the martyred
heroines of a holy crusade
for freedom and
human dignity.
And so this afternoon in
a real sense they have
something to say to
each of us in their death.
They have something to say
to every minister of the
gospel who has remained
silent behind the safe
security of
stained-glass windows.
They have something to say
to every politician who has
fed his constituents with
the stale bread of hatred
and the spoiled
meat of racism.
They have something to say
to a federal government that
has compromised with the
undemocratic practices of
southern Dixiecrats and
the blatant hypocrisy of
right-wing
northern Republicans.
They have something to
say to every Negro who has
passively accepted the evil
system of segregation and
who has stood on the
sidelines in a mighty
struggle for justice.
They say to each of us,
black and white alike,
that we must substitute
courage for caution.
They say to us that we
must be concerned not merely
about who murdered
them, but about the system,
the way of life, the
philosophy which produced
the murderers.
Their death says to us that
we must work passionately
and unrelentingly for the
realization of the American
dream. And so my friends,
they did not die in vain."
King giving the eulogy at
the funeral honoring the
four young girls
who were blown,
blown, blown up. This is
a King you don't hear much
about, a King
who's despairing,
who's exhausted, and feels
hopeless. It's important to
know that King ran through
the whole vector of human
emotion, certainly, and was
on more than one occasion
pushed to the
limits. Other people,
of course,
pushed to the limits,
acting out in different
kinds of ways. I began
today's lecture playing
a clip from "We Shall
Overcome," a song talking
about--I mean doesn't take
much to read into
it--overcoming those moments
when you are taxed beyond
belief. It's an anthem of
the movement; it's a very
important song. We know
it. Even if you
don't know the words,
you can fake sing
through it. You know,
people next to you can
sing a little louder,
cover up the fact you don't
know what the next line is.
But you know how
the tune goes,
right? But we don't hear
about other artists offering
different interpretations of
this moment. After the four
young women are
blown up, Nina Simone,
a famous jazz artist,
produces a protest song. It
becomes one of her
signature pieces,
much like Billie Holiday's
"Strange Fruit." It's a
very long song.
I'm going to play, you know,
a portion of it. The lyrics
should be clear enough, but
I'll actually show them up
here as well. It's
called "Mississippi Goddam."
[Nina Simone: (singing)]
"Alabama's gotten me so
upset, Tennessee
made me lose my rest,
And everybody knows
about Mississippi Goddam,
This is a show tune, But the
show hasn't been written for
it, yet, Hound
dogs on my trail,
School children
sitting in jail,
Black cat cross my path, I
think every day's gonna be
my last, Lord have
mercy on this land of mine,
We all gonna get
it in due time,
I don't belong here,
I don't belong there,
I've even stopped
believing in prayer,
Don't tell me, I tell you,
Me and my people just about
due, I've been
there so I know,
They keep on saying 'Go
slow!' But that's just the
trouble, 'do it slow',
Washing the windows,
'do it slow',
Picking the cotton,
'do it slow', You're
just plain rotten,
'do it slow',
You're too damn lazy,
'do it slow', The
thinking's crazy,
'do it slow',
Where am I going,
What am I
doing, I don't know,
I don't know, Just try
to do your very best,
Stand up be counted
with all the rest,
For everybody knows
about Mississippi Goddam,
I made you thought I
was kiddin' didn't we.
Picket lines,
School boycotts,
They try to say
it's a communist plot,
All I want is equality,
for my sister my brother my
people and me, Yes you
lied to me all these years,
You told me to wash
and clean my ears,
And talk real fine
just like a lady,
And you'd stop
calling me Sister Sadie,
Oh but this whole
country is full of lies,
You're all gonna die
and die like flies,
I don't trust you any
more, You keep on saying 'Go
slow!' 'Go slow!' But
that's just the trouble,
'do it slow',
Desegregation, 'do it slow',
Mass
participation, 'do it slow',
Reunification, 'do it
slow', Do things gradually,
'do it slow', But
bring more tragedy,
'do it slow', Why
don't you see it,
Why don't you feel
it, I don't know,
I don't know, You don't
have to live next to me,
Just give me my equality,
Everybody knows about
Mississippi, Everybody
knows about Alabama,
Everybody knows about
Mississippi Goddam.
That's it!"
Now it's a genius
song, and since it,
you know, it's played to the
tune of a bouncy show tune
and she was known
for doing, you know,
jazz standards
and her own songs,
playing the American
songbook. And then she's
telling her largely white
audiences to go to hell.
And they ate it
up. That, you know,
she's calling the people
who expected civil rights
activists to be respectable,
wash behind their ears,
to hell with that as well.
And the beloved country that
King is talking about, that
can go to hell as well. In
fact, it is going to hell,
because they just blew up
four children and no
one's going to pay the
consequences for it. This
is an important narrative of
the civil rights movement.
You need to understand
it. And you also need to
understand the fact
that it's dropped out,
and that's really the,
the significance of it all,
is that we know certain
things about the movement
and not others, and we need
to ask the question why.
That brings to close my
lecture. The TAs are going
to fan out a little
separately over here to
distribute your papers and
your midterm exams. And
even though I know you
have other classes to go to,
I wish you a
lovely spring break.
Thanks.